[Music]
nostalgia is a powerful emotion games
like Goldeneye and Diddy Kong Racing
were staples in my youth and ate up more
time than I'd like to admit but
revisiting these iconic title shows them
for what they've become outmoded dated
clumsy relics of a lost era but that
doesn't mean old games are necessarily
worse than new when it comes to
long-running series like battlefield and
Call of Duty
people often decry the newer releases
and longed for the good old days as it
were and to be frank I'm guilty of this
myself the first to call of duty games
stick in my mind that some of the best
shooter campaigns I've ever played in
the early battlefield games provided my
most memorable multiplayer experiences
to date and despite the sad state of the
series in present day I still think
about those battlefield rounds of days
gone by the wide-open maps the intense
focus on teamwork the sandbox chaos of
each match as it unfolded into a unique
tapestry of narrative but what was it
about the early battlefield titles that
got lost along the way
what happened to that magic well PC
purists have long been claiming the
battlefield 2 was the pinnacle of the
series and I'm inclined to agree
so after Aaron Samson's recent piece
claiming bad company 2 was the best of
the franchise I felt compelled to delve
back into bf 2 and see if the dolphin
diving nade spamming madness was still
everything my rose-colored memory was
making it out to be and to be completely
and utterly frank this game is still fun
as hell there are so many things to love
about battlefield to the introduction of
commander mode the first appearance of
squads the feeling of being an
inconsequential soldier and a massive
battlefield the wealth of classes and
most importantly the maps oh the maps
strike a car Ken Master Sharkey
Peninsula the revivified Wake Island
2007 these massive dynamic killing
fields for what made battlefield 2 so
memorable for me you could go from
holding down a terrace to city block to
advancing up a wide-open pasture within
the same minute in each segmented piece
of these maps felt independently
excellent as a skirmish setting while
maintaining a balanced cohesion with the
larger flow of combat battles felt like
they had almost tangible tides that
could be turned with a sneaky flag cat
from the rear you could sense that an
enemy's defense had been broken as they
fell back and your squad mates surged
forward for a capture and beyond that
these maps were so open there weren't
three routes you could choose to take
from the spawn point for the action
there was just the battle ahead of you
and your own decision-making and skills
to guide you creative approaches that
push the limits were met with success
instead of stifled by boundaries
battlefield 2 is a game that rewarded
players with a unique sense of freedom
and therefore personal responsibility
while one man could shift the momentum
of an entire match only in rare moments
this served to encourage teamwork in the
cooperation of squads instead of the
classic approach of grabbing a
disposable aircraft on your own and
parachuting into the action beyond that
a squads class diversity was essential
without an anti-tank a single enemy and
APC could repel an onslaught without a
medic here expeditions into enemy
territory would prove short-lived
the squad's spawn also only allowed
players to spawn on their squad leader
forcing whomever that was to move
carefully and make tactical decisions
based on group success not personal
success this was a game that took
sacrifice to win this was a game where a
squad leader would throw down an attack
order and the entire squad would
coalesce to capture a point as one unit
you've been playing this week I can't
remember the last time I felt so much
cooperation amongst a group of strangers
playing a video game over the internet
however I can't say that bf2 is
everything my time addled memories make
it out to be the grenade spam is truly
life ruining it's depression inducing
it's hair pulling Lee awful it has only
matched by the amount of claim or death
that I was subjected to these two
explosive accessories single-handedly
paint this damn near perfect game and
account for more than half of my debts
it's not that I disapprove of any means
beyond bullets the artillery strikes are
either devastating or highly satisfying
depending on which side you end up on
but they never leave you feeling cheated
in addition to this the aircraft and
battlefield are also a bit strangely
balanced the Jets especially are almost
too agile and powerful but the upshot is
that they seem to be made of paper a
single well-placed anti-aircraft
installation can repel an aerial strike
with ease but it doesn't often feel like
Jets interact with the battle in a
meaningful way they just do their damage
and leave a trail of butthurt in our
wake lastly I have to make mention of
the hit detection and weapon feedback
in the game there were moments when I
wasn't even sure that I had successfully
killed somebody without checking the
text log and the smallest ping spike
could mean that easy kills were lost in
the cyclone of frustration and latency
the foggy draw distances of 2005 and
often muddled textures didn't help us
and on occasion I felt confused as to
where my bullets were naturally going
battlefield 2 is one of a small handful
of games that I personally consider a
masterpiece it was such an enormous leap
forward from the first two titles that
the difference is undeniable and only a
year after the release of battlefield
vietnam almost a decade later
battlefield 2 somehow holds up in spite
of its rampant explosive spamming and
dated visuals not only does it live on
in my mind is a great game but somehow
it actually lives up to all those warm
fuzzy memories
[Music]